I love to go to the death baby that's
God Oh Dan did you know how to fight
come on room no I want easily sound
right uh on November third journey to a
whole new world of entertainment and
upgrade to the ultimate movie experience
in Cinemark XD what were you the god of
again
Thor Ragnarok November 3rd in Cinemark
XD so much has happened since I saw you
lost Miami like yesterday but still
pretty fresh then I went on a journey of
self-discovery
I love you
[Music]
Wow you have no idea however God is
attached is invaded as God oh I miss
this
and you and I have fighters me come on
now I want easily some sound right Oh
[Music]
God is dead little be reborn in my image
I thought you'd be glad to see me
Mira stopper here now prevent Ragnarok
the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
like the old days
surprise discuss fun
hi
there is a fighter
here we go
I'm not a cream or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god all again
[Music]
we're the same unite just a couple of
hotheaded fools
yes saying all kite choir toilet water
I can't does my client the whole like
raging fire - I like smoldering fire
you